king of all blacks called in yesterday
too he was quite a hit
he sent me a video it's quite amazing he
lost 74 pounds on ozempic and I gotta
say [__] guy is really thin oh is
that big in the house just wanted to
shoot a little video to show you how
much weight I lost yes king of all
blacks it's for you Howard and Robin
yeah baby I'm spelled I made a comeback
74 pounds shout out to those epic once a
week and you can look like me isn't that
something amazing yeah he's thin I don't
think we've ever seen him that size
pisses me off because you know
I just love that I have the willpower to
be thin and now now that that's not even
a superpower anymore everyone's walking
around thin they keep saying here's how
much weight I lost no you didn't right
it's ozympic that lost the way everybody
has a radio show everybody's skinny I
mean what is this
what's going on